[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économique du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines avec nous jean
michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bonsoir bonsoir alors avec vous
on va revenir sur l'année économique
2021 à saint quentin en yvelines on va
parler du plan de relance de la
stratégie de renault groupe présent à
guyancourt avec le technocentre puis
nous reviendrons sur la formation et
l'enseignement supérieur mais tout
d'abord jean michel fourgous vous êtes
déplacé à dubaï à l'exposition
universelle actuellement donc à dubaï
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quel
message vous êtes allés porter vous avez
parlé de l'école numérique notamment
c'est ça absolument donc on était
invités
à cette grande exposition mondiale pour
témoigner un peu de
l'innovation française notamment sur
l'éducation effectivement on a
inventer ou créés il encourt d'abord
puis à saint quentin en yvelines une
vraie réforme de l'éducation
notamment de toucher à la pédagogique
est quand même le
métier essentiel mais ceux de
l'éducation nationale 7 est longue c'est
difficile mais aujourd'hui il ya une
transformation
vous apprenez que numérique mais sûre
c'est beaucoup plus convivial pour un
enfant c'est beaucoup plus attractif
c'est il travaille beaucoup plus de
façon collective
s'il a plus confiance en lui il a moins
peur de l'erreur
je dirais que ça peut rien à voir et en
plus ça rend plus autonome
ça ça ça va être plus de plus
communiquer et d'apprendre plus vite
avec plus de plaisir - et même chose
pour les profs ça permet un prof de
d'apprendre avec plus de plaisir donc
quand vous prenez dans l'épreuve
prennent plus de plaisir à prendre et
que les élèves prennent plus de plaisir
à apprendre à priori voilà c'est quand
même pas mal donc que cette technique
qui effectivement se diffuse dans le
monde n'est pas que mais on a été en
france inde est un des grands promoteurs
de cela à tel point qu on ait eu quand
j'étais député j'ai une mission
parlementaire pour aller voir en france
et pour simuler les régions et
départements effectivement apporter à
dubai finalement c'est le message en
disant que quand même temps que le fait
que demain le monde entier et les mêmes
techniques pour apprendre peut-être avec
des contenus aussi proche plus proche
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui ben çà çà çà çà
diminuera les écarts
d'information de formation donc de
perception du monde et peut-être que le
monde entier s'entendre à mieux se
comprendre à mieux et en fait que je
pense que même en synthèse à dubaï train
dit c'est que je pense que même pour la
paix dans le monde je pense que c'est
une
belle une bonne chose de l'arrivée de
cette révolution de la pédagogie pour
apprendre aux enfants alors jean michel
fourgous à venir à saint quentin en
yvelines est l'une des actualités annuel
de cette année à saint quentin en
yvelines c'était le déploiement du plan
de relance 10 millions d'euros ont été
attribués à 25 entreprises du territoire
il ya des projets industriels ou des
projets de recherche et de développement
qui ont été soutenues quel bilan vous
faites de ces aides attribuées aux
entreprises de votre territoire eh bien
j'ai cessé une entreprise ça un marché
ça connaît ce marché et ça c'est sentir
un nouveau produit a lancé ou à
renforcer ou à développer bon et donc
mais heureusement des entreprises sont
moins capitalisées que leurs concurrents
anglais français anglais allemands
américains donc il s'agit de renforcer
bien sûr le les fonds propres ce qu'on
appelle le capital d'une entreprise pour
qu'elle puisse up l'ancien nouveau
projet faire de la r&d donc c'est ça qui
ont été essentiels par rapport à ça les
aides ont été
[Musique]
très importante dans la mesure où il y
avait une baisse du chiffre d'affaires
c'est mondiale d'une crise mondiale une
baisse bien entendu on ne pouvait plus
payer aux salariés quand vous n'avez
plus de rentrée c'était comme une crise
d'une violence je rappelle que c'est
l'équivalent delà de la guerre 14-18
parce que j'ai eu entre 10 et 20
millions de morts je pense que vous y
êtes puisqu'il ya un facteur 2 ou 3
d'erreurs ça sent la même des gars donc
c'est grave donc bien sûr que cette
crise a impacté l'entreprise et
l'entreprise d'en trouver c'est la ville
entreprise c'est ce qu'ils payent votre
retraite c'est ce qu'ils payent votre
santé pratiquant social c'est ce qu'ils
payent les locaux c'est ce qu'ils payent
l'agglomération de saint jacques fait
conscients les salaires le pouvoir
d'achat des jambons donc il a fallu bien
sûr sécurisé les entreprises et bien une
rue en termes de produits que vous avez
évoquées qui ont été données par la
région par l'état aussi par la région
par là par rabat par le département et
par saint quentin pour bien sûr
identifier les secteurs les plus les
plus vulnérables et les sécuriser il est
protégé faire une sorte de cordon
sanitaire je ne prétends pas qu'on a
réussi surtout mais je peux dire que c
était dense en ile-de-france 13
opérations et la région a joué un rôle d
extrêmement stratégique
bien sûr pour sauver protéger maintenant
on aura certainement en juin 2022 à un
moment aussi de vérité sur la situation
économique selon les périodes
électorales aux grandes et du mal à voir
les vrais chiffres on va dire les choses
donc on attend le mois de juin pour
savoir et voir comment on peut bien sûr
parce qu'il y aura samedi moments
difficiles et on le sait il ya la
relance est là on l'a vu justement cette
année tout au long de l'année nous
sommes allés dans les entreprises du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et on va voir des exemples justement
d'entreprises ont bénéficié du plan de
relance
[Musique]
doit à la fois gérer aujourd'hui mais on
a aussi prévoir demain et donc investir
dans l'innovation pouvoir propulsé style
and design dans une eau créative qui va
intéresser les marchés c'est à la fois
pouvoir personnaliser l'intérieur avions
et offrir de nouvelles nouveaux outils
de nouvelles
opportunités pour les pour les
compagnies aériennes d'aller chercher de
la ce qu'on appelle la borne d'extérieur
[Musique]
notre rôle c'est de concevoir des
systèmes qui vont purifier cette haute
ville pour la rendre propre à
l'utilisation par les scientifiques que
ce soit dans la recherche contre la
cancérologie par exemple en cancérologie
ou pour ce soit des analyses chimiques
dans l'environnement l'alimentaire
[Musique]
les concepts débats et des grands
marchés vrac y va c'est un débat idées
de centre ville et qu'on installe en
périphérie et sur lesquelles on va
rajouter tous les produits frais avec
des commerçants engagé locaux qui m'ont
rejoint dans le projet pour défendre les
mêmes valeurs que celles que je voulais
porter avec des valides et
[Musique]
jean michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines dans ce dernier numéro du sky
échos de l'année 2021 alors on vient de
le voir un donc les entreprises relance
ont relancé grâce au plan de relance et
il ya aussi des grands groupes présents
sur notre territoire et notamment
renault qui a annoncé une renault lution
en début d'année 2021 une réorientation
stratégique du groupe avec un impact sur
le technocentre qu'est ce que vous savez
aujourd'hui de l'impact aujourd'hui de
cette renault lution sur le technocentre
à saint quentin en yvelines il vient
d'abord qu'il y ait de très belle très
belle entreprise et bien sûr qu'ils sont
dans dans cette opération
damman sein cinq grandes entreprises qui
en fait mettre ensemble leurs
savoir-faire en en
intelligence artificielle en 5 g en
puisque cette touche de cearà tous cas
automatisation de demain c'est très très
5 très belle entreprise qui représente
en avant le savoir faire français et et
bien sûr et c'est de cette confrontation
de savoir-faire de compétences que l'on
va encore franchir certainement des
étapes nouvelles en innovation ces
secteurs de bien sûr mais secteur
aéronautique c'est de tout ce qui est
technologique est très présent bien sûr
dans
sur sur 7 sur ce territoire c'est tout
ce qui est cybersécurité également
puisque si vous avez vous n'aurez pas de
voiture autonome demain si vous n'avez
pas d'hier sécurité votre téléphone ou
autre le portable votre pc ou à vous
vous ne pourrez plus l'utiliser dans des
jeux pendant les 12 mois si vous n'avez
pas une cyber sécurité qui s'organise vu
la montée en puissance des attaques donc
voilà est donc ici saint quentin en
yvelines à à ce secteur
de de la cybersécurité pour prévenir et
pour préparer bien sûr des réponses vous
l'avez vu sur les attaques de ce virus
on sait aussi armé des réponses fortes
plus on a réouvert d'ailleurs l'accès à
la vaccination qui est avec si les
dizaines de milliers de salariés au
passage d'entreprise bon et bien entendu
il s'agit de d'être capable de faire des
contre attaques c'est vrai sur plan
sanitaire mais c'est le vrai on sait qu
en cybersécurité alors je vous rappelle
que l'exemple de renault c'est c'est
quand même donc ce qu'on appelle un peu
là la software république effectivement
vous avez parlé des cinq groupes qui
sont réunis autour du groupe renault
juste avant de vous faire réagir sur la
sauve toi république on va tout de suite
écouté le directeur général lucas demeo
du le directeur général du groupe
renault que nous avions rencontrée à
l'art factory de fleurs écoutez
technocentre ça restera un peu le centre
de de la techno de
de renault donc on a bien
l'intérêt et la stratégie de focaliser
les équipes sur tous les métiers du
futur toutes les technologies vidéo ici
en france est la seule république en
fait c'est un écosystème concret au tour
avec d'autres entreprises comme estimé
que lektronix thales orange atos
dassault systèmes excellent ou créer un
écosystème de la tech qui nous permettra
éventuellement aussi de voilà de
comparer des roadmaps technologique des
projets extra et ça marche bien je suis
très content on vient d'entendre le
directeur général c'est un focus
vraiment très intéressant pour le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
m le la panse penser la technologie de
demain par rapport à la mobilité de
demain oui c'est cette année qu'au
système de très haute valeur ajoutée
d'ailleurs il faut bien comprendre ça
c'est quand on crée des emplois
aujourd'hui il faut on a beaucoup de des
doutes c'est entre mille milliards de
dettes de son bien déficit budgétaire il
faut vraiment que la croissance il faut
il faut il faut une hyper croissance
pour sauver le pays
est en fait le premier facteur de la
croissance cessé quand vous associez des
secteurs comme ça avec le numérique
c'est le plus gros levier de croissance
mondiale de croissance et est évident
classé d exemple les entreprises qui se
rassemble derrière cette révolution
technique c'est bon signe c'est plutôt
rassurant je pense quand la france en
plus c'est des structures extrêmement
forte en r&d vous savez qu'on a le
crédit impôt recherche qu'on a sur
lequel 50 a joué un rôle très important
cathy voté par mais mme pécresse
mais je dirais que c'est certainement
quelque chose qui a protégé
l'intelligence protéger nos chercheurs
de très haute valeur ajoutée et on en a
les effets secondaires aujourd'hui
positif c'est que dans cette crise et on
l'a vu par little heures difficiles et
ducati mais on voit bien mais même dans
une crise bien à saint quentin on s'est
organisé en une journée on passe du delà
de la pédagogie
présentiel pédagogie distant ciel mais
même chose on l'a vu toutes ces
entreprises est de trop de leur ajouter
tous savent faire travailler aussi leurs
salariés à distance et c'est bien sûr un
très gros un très gros mais bien
privilège d'en novembre devant des
crises par herman on a des écoles aussi
doux que des écoles sujets abordés avec
justement sur l'enseignement supérieur
quelle quelle est la stratégie
aujourd'hui de saint quentin en yvelines
par rapport à l'enseignement supérieur
un domaine que vous soutenez finalement
à travers des fonds ou des regroupements
aussi et c'est très des filiations entre
école et entreprise là oui on crée des
synergies ici on met des fonds
d'ailleurs aussi avec des partenaires
pour accélérer
ces rapprochements entre un laboratoire
une entreprise d'une université ccc ccc
à une productivité très forte quand vous
arrivez à rassembler des équipes comme
ça et c'est ce qui manque peut-être
aussi en france on le fait un peu mais
il faut faire le plus de 50 1 et paris
saclay souhaite être un peu un peu en
leader dans ces opérations de
rapprochement ont visé des bureaux des
écoles qui fonctionne très bien enfin il
y en a beaucoup mais en blaise takacs et
une école d'ingénieurs spécialisée sur
la filière mobilité on parlait de talent
aussi et qui est vraiment dans les dents
les nouveaux défis de demain vous avez
déjà
un des bus autonome qui circulent mais
demain pour l'idiot on pense que vous
honorez et que se sera montré au monde
entier le savoir faire français devrait
être monté bon vous avez des débits
entre moustey comme même troisième
l'institut national de l'image et du son
ticket haussier qui produit 6 noeuds
haute valeur ajoutée dans cette
industrie très créative vous à l'école
de 1600 qui est la première école
française en alternance d'ailleurs
dédiée à la cybersécurité donc c'est ce
secteur qui va exploser et bien donc
nous on se prépare à attaquer les
secteurs stratégiques de haute valeur
ajoutée qui vont produire de l'emploi
durable de l'emploi qui va démultiplier
la richesse voilà parce que il ya des
emplois il faut dire là c'est le monde
change la vie et des emplois
malheureusement faudra abandonner pour
ancrer deux fois plus ou trois fois plus
dans notre fils est un succès c'est
aussi le rôle des politiques de savoir
où il est toujours recréer s'adapter à
la modernité voilà vous avez bien sûr
les sept écoles qui n'arrivait l'école
sur l agriculture qui dit bien où son
campus en demandant de très belle très
belle école d'ingénieurs aussi
vous avez le réseau skyteam dont vous
avez parlé qui renforce le lien bien sûr
économique et le monde académique faut
pas laisser s'isoler des jeunes comme ça
en dehors du avec des théories c'est
bien il faut les théories mais il faut
tout de suite les mettre en pratique
c'est quand même la rencontre entre
l'expérience
et et le et une exposition théorique
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de compétence tant
que le temps que l'individu n'a pas
confrontés ces théories à à la réalité
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi donc c'était une
émission spéciale avec jean michel
fourgous le président de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines on se
retrouve en janvier 2022 à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]